obviously I congratulate Boris Johnson
on his election as Trudy party leader
despite our differences and we have many
of them I'll do everything I can to
develop a way of working with him that
is constructive and to take some respect
Scotland's interests and views but of
course I can't deny be hypocritical to
deny the fact that I have profound
concerns about the prospect of Boris
Johnson as play Minister you know the
vast majority of people had Scotland had
they been given any choice which they
were then wouldn't have chosen to hand
the keys to number 10 to somebody with
Boris Johnson's views and track record
so people Scotland I'm sure many people
across the whole of the UK will be very
concerned about the prospect of his
Premiership he's got the opportunity now
of course to prove people wrong I'm not
sure of whether he will do so the duty
is certainly out there and that's
probably as it may oddly as I could fit
it right I mean there was a democratic
process and that process led to a leave
decision and Boris Johnson is simply
planning to implement that decision
well there was a democratic process in
Scotland the outcome of that democratic
process was 62% of people voted against
brexit a similar proportion voted for
anti brexit parties and the recent
European elections my job as First
Minister of Scotland is to represent
those views and to do everything I can
to avoid Scotland be taken out of the EU
against their will and in particular to
block any attempt to take the UK out of
the EU with no deal because Boris
Johnson no matter how hard he may try
can Ottoman team that he's got a mandate
for a new deal Britain
well I mean he's got a mandate certainly
from this morning's result but if you're
if you're MPs and if you really wanted
to if if your MPs really wanted to stop
no deal you could have got them to vote
for Theresa Mays deal today's amis deal
was a bad deal it would have taken us
out of the EU with no clarity about what
came a deal and the SNP are not going to
vote for things well you know it's like
the fire or the frying pan our job is
not to just always look for the least
worst option I'm maybe old-fashioned in
politics but I still think the job of
politicians should be to work for and
campaign for and argue for the best for
the people that they represent and for
Scotland that is not leaving the EU at
all now you know Boris Johnson who said
that he's determined to leave on the
31st of October with no deal well I'll
put them on notice that me my government
the SNP will do everything we can to
block that because it would be
catastrophic for people's jobs and
livelihoods and living standards it
would have you know a modern country
like the UK talking about whether the
kids secure medicine supplies it defies
logic and common sense and any political
leader that sought to do that would have
no discipline or regard at all for the
basic well-being of the citizens the
length and breadth of the UK isn't it in
your interest in some way for Boris
Johnson to pursue a no deal because that
in your view may bolster your argument
for an independence referendum again
look I don't want to see things happen
that do real damage to the UK I didn't
want Breck sir I told Adam Ward Boris
Johnson is pre-med astir so I take no
pleasure in what's happening in the UK
right now but certainly it does make the
case for Scotland having the ability to
choose an alternative all the stronger
because right now we are simply having
to accept decisions that we don't want
that have profound consequences for our
future and that against our will if
we're an independent country we can
choose our own future and build
relationships maintain and build
relationships with others across the UK
Europe and further afield that's a far
better prospect for Scotland than a
Boris Johnson Premiership taking his out
of the EU against okay just two more
quick ones is this in your view could
this be how the United Kingdom ends
I think Scotland will become an
independent country I think everything
that has happened over the past few
years yes I think Boris Johnson becoming
Prime Minister she sees the the
probability for it now become an
independent country every poll since the
last independence referendum she was
raised in support for independence we
had a pool a couple of weeks ago showing
majority support in the scenario where
Boris Johnson becomes prime minister but
ultimately of course it's a positive
case it's a case for Scotland being a
charge of our own destiny
taking the decisions that are right for
Scotland having good constructive
relationships with other parts of the
British Isles with Europe and others
across the world the positive keys for
independence and I think Scotland will
get there sooner rather than later all
right and just finally when Boris
Johnson if he does make his tour of the
UK his tour of the Union you'll meet him
quite happily will you
look I'm the First Minister of Scotland
I've met and dealt with Boris Johnson's
predecessors to these a million David
Cameron and Boris Johnson's the thought
prime minister in my tenure as First
Minister I will seek to have the same
relationship with Boris Johnson we'll
meet some talk to him
I will not disguise the many differences
we have but I'll make the case for the
interests of the country I serve and
represent as First Minister and you know
I would do that with Boris Johnson as I
have done with his predecessors what I
would say is I hope Boris Johnson shows
more of a willingness to listen to
Scotland and respect her views than his
immediate predecessor has done